[Music]
Frank welcome to the heavy spoilers show
I'm your host definition aka mr. marvel
and with a brand new Avengers game right
around the corner it's the perfect time
to go back and revisit the original
project that was supposed to be centered
around the MCU throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything you
need to know about the cancelled
Avengers game as well as all the
gameplay mechanics story and more before
we dive into him fully let me take you
way back to 2012 the MCU was just about
to become the most successful movie
universe of all time and whilst it was
making a huge impact on the big screen
that been many failed attempts to try
and replicate this in the video game
market whether it was Ironman 1 & 2 the
Captain America spin-off game or many of
the mobile titles nothing really seemed
to be cracking the market in the same
way that the Arkham franchise had slowly
started - in 2010 at THQ acquired the
rights to produce an Avengers video game
that was set to launch in 2012 across
all platforms in line with the film
however this game was not meant to be a
pure adaptation of the film and was
instead a completely original piece
featuring enemies like the super Skrulls
are more originally it was planned to be
a third-person action game in the same
vein as some of the adaptations that
come before it
however after doing rigorous testing
with Captain America to see how the
combat could play out THQ decided to
switch to a first-person view that would
put you in the perspective of your
favorite heroes whilst I've seen some
sources report that this was because
there were several other third-person
games out at the time involving the
heroes that didn't really deliver and
personally think this change was made
due to the popularity of first
some shooters such as Call of Duty you
can even see from some of the early
gameplay footage that XP counters
littered the screen similar to Cod and
give off the impression of the building
points towards leveling up the game was
to be heavily based around co-op with
each player entering the sort of arena
as their chosen avenger to take on waves
of enemies the many arenas ranged around
king of the hill at death matches
capture the flag and more each character
had a different set of abilities with
Hulk and Thor being more about brute
strength whereas Iron Man and Captain
America were fast agile and able to fire
projectiles each player could perform an
assist on an enemy which played out in a
third-person finishing noob and really
feels like big WOW moments when you're
watching the gameplay THQ really wanted
this to play out like the Avengers did
on the big screen with each one of them
working together to combat the Skrull
invasion which is what the story was
centered around the plot was penned by
Brian Michael Bendis who had written
Secret Invasion which heavily focused
around the scrolls and it's definitely
clear that THQ were trying to make this
graphic novel the main focus of the
game's narrative the scrolls as I'm sure
many of you know can mimic the
appearance and abilities of heroes and
lots of the boss bowels were takes on
different characters such as Wolverine
Spider Woman and more the game opens
with the scrolls trapping the Fantastic
Four in the negative zone before setting
their sights on the world and tried to
take down the planet this worldwide war
would see the heroes jumping from
location to location and many of the
early concept art shows places like
Triskelion the Helicarrier New York and
the Savage Land this was all in an
effort to take down the scrolls but
other plot elements and side bosses
focused around Ultron and an evil
version of vision which the characters
would have to face off against on their
quest in the end the heroes would go up
against the Queen scroll and a
genetically modified super scroller had
been created underground by the villains
the game finished with the event is of
course winning but apparently it's set
sequels involving more characters from
the universe so why did it get canceled
well by 2011 that the game was still
massively behind as with most movie
tie-ins there's always a looming
deadline and perhaps the project wasn't
as permitting to the experimentation
that THQ are wishing to do what the work
at one point the studio even outsourced
it to Blue Tongue Entertainment who
worked on a lot of environment pieces
and the PC port THQ at this point was
spending a lot of money on this game in
order to make a success however after
the release of homefront which caused a
massive stock crash of more than 20% in
24 hours for the company the business
went into dire straits add to this there
you draw project which bomb massively
and you have a company that is barely
getting by due to a number of bad
choices and the projects that
disappointed in order to try and delay
the company's inevitable crash and gain
some sure footing directors of the
business decided that now was the time
to cut back on the bigger projects that
were ballooning in price and thus the
Avengers game became the first thing
from the firing line this is jus
massively to the inflation of the
Australian dollar in 2011 which also
meant that THQ were paying a lot more
for the same amount of work and thus
layoffs had to happen and there simply
wasn't enough manpower to maintain the
project the game was very near
completion but apparently even this
wasn't enough to save it THQ Australia
was shut down and after failing to
secure funding from Marvel they were
unable to continue such an expensive
venture whilst I'm sure many of us wish
that we could take a trip back into the
quantum realm to save this game whatever
it takes unfortunately it seems like
it's something that's forever going to
be lost I as I'm sure you would have
loved to play there but I guess we'll
never get the chance to now that Tech
has moved so far forward and the MCU has
changed in so many ways
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the game and if you're looking
forward to the new Avengers 1 coming out
next year which hopefully will redeem
this console project comment below and
let me know and if you enjoy this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my breakdown of all the far
from home spoilers that we have from the
premiere it covers all of the apparent
ins and outs of the plot so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
more about the MC movie I leave that
linked at the end and I'll see you over
there
after this video this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]